German Chancellor Olaf Schultz is facing
criticism for his slow reaction to
remarks made by the Palestinian
president Mahmoud Abbas during a visit
to Berlin speaking at a press conference
with the German Chancellor on Tuesday
evening Abbas said Israel had committed
50 holocausts against Palestinians
sparking an outpouring of anger here in
Germany the chancellor later said he was
disgusted by The Commons but critics say
he was too slow to respond
it was this moment at the very end of
the press conference that caused outrage
foreign
since 1947
to the present day
Israel has carried out 50 massacres
in 50 Palestinian villages
50 massacres
50 holocausts and until today every day
every day our people get killed by the
Israeli Army
Germany's leading tabloid build called
it a holocaust scandal at the
Chancellor's office
but it wasn't only a bus Comet that
sparked outraged it was also this
reaction from Olaf Schultz
the press conference was concluded as
planned with no visible attempt by
Schultz to contradict our bus
he should have told him to leave tweeted
conservative opposition leader
friedrichments
you shouldn't go into a press conference
with Mr Abbas without having sought
before about provocations of this kind
which should be expected and then you
know that you have to react because
it's Berlin it's a German chancellor and
it's a German chancellor
amid growing pressure Schultz responded
with his own tweet
for us Germans in particular any
relativization of the singularity of the
Holocaust is intolerable and
unacceptable
during Wednesday's press conference
Schultz spokesperson took the blame for
the lack of immediate reaction and made
it clear there would be consequences
the German Chancellor expects the
Palestinian president to recognize the
singularity of the Holocaust without any
qualification his gaffe yesterday casts
a dark shadow over Germany's
relationship with the Palestinian
Authority
mahuda bus toned down his message in a
new statement but his Holocaust remarks
have already strained German Palestinian
relations
I asked DW political correspondent Simon
young about the reactions this
controversial press conference has
spurred in Germany
yeah well this whole incident has
sparked a storm of reaction with even
for instance the normally reticent
former Chancellor Angela Merkel who
hasn't said much since he Lester left
office last year
condemning the remarks of the
Palestinian president but it's not just
about his remarks as you say it's also
about the uh slow reaction from
Chancellor Schultz and some people have
called that uh you know unprofessional
and there is this story that the
Chancellor's media advisor effectively
brought the press conference to an end
before the chancellor uh was about to
say something
um well you know that's fair enough but
I think the chancellor of Germany ought
to be responsible for his own actions uh
the uh leader of the opposition
Christian Democrat Party has called it
incomprehensible he says the that our
best should not just have been
contradicted he should have been told to
leave the chancellery rather than being
offered the handshake that uh Schultz
immediately thereafter did offer him and
there have been some negative comments
as well from Jewish leaders here and
other opposition politicians uh I think
uh you know you're seeing a lot of
aftermath a lot of broken porcelain uh
as they say on the floor and there's a
lot of repair work for the German
government to do they have summoned the
Palestinian representative in Berlin
today and told him of the government's
position on this yeah talking about
broken porcelain how do you think this
will affect german-palestinian relations
well some politicians are saying that
it's time to look again at the
development funding for the Palestinian
Authority more than a billion euros has
been promised from Germany we're making
it one of the biggest donors if not the
biggest some people are saying uh you
know Abbas is a uh supports terrorism
he's also a holocaust denier he's not
the sort of person who should be in
receipt of these uh kind of funds it's
fair to say in that press conference
Abbas was saying he hoped that
Chancellor Schultz would soon visit
Ramallah and the West Bank well the
Chancellor's press spokesman today was
saying it's very hard to imagine that
happening anytime in the foreseeable
future TW political correspondent Simon
young thanks so much